after sharing their grief so publicly
and with so many the king and his
siblings had some peace as they
continued to mourn their mother
the queen's four children mounted a
vigil around her coffin lying at rest in
saint giles cathedral in edinburgh
although members of the public were
watching it still felt like a private
and very personal moment
the queen will remain here till this
evening
those who've already seen her faced
hours of queuing with a line stretching
over a mile away from the cathedral
going in and seeing her ladies at rest
in the coffee has been absolutely
incredible if she
had lay in state straight in london i
don't think we'd have got the
opportunity to see
[Music]
it it was a distinctly scottish farewell
to her majesty as her coffin left the
palace of hollyrood house earlier in the
day
[Music]
thousands gathered to catch a glimpse of
the somber stately procession along the
royal mile
god bless the queen
and later the scottish parliament held a
two-minute silence
the queen and her love of this land
remembered by the new monarch
my mother felt as i do the
greatest admiration for the scottish
people
for their magnificent achievements
and their indomitable spirit
the king is now preparing to travel to
belfast continuing his tour of the
united kingdom while her majesty's
coffin will be flown to england
the queen will then be brought to
buckingham palace here she'll be placed
in the bow room where members of the
royal household will have the chance to
pay their respects
ahead of the arrival of her coffin
rehearsals are underway for its
procession to the palace of westminster
there the queen will lie in state for
four days before her funeral with
hundreds of thousands of people expected
to turn out
a spectacle and a moment in history that
so many want to be a part of becky
kochel sky news buckingham palace